everyone loved that song
[Music]
rick chavez is a musician who has lived
in las vegas for
25 years he vividly remembers the legend
trini lopez he was big in the 60s
what happened was like he recorded a
song
that peter paul and mary did it was an
old
1940s song
it was called if i had a hammer
and unlike many trini had a style one
will always remember he had a unique
way of strumming kind of like where he
hid it and he did it
in uh more of a rock style and that was
kind of like the beginning of
what it was called um folk rock a hammer
musician rick arroyo moved to las vegas
in 1995
and says in the 60s you would hear a lot
of different styles of music
but not a whole lot of transitions like
that that's a nice
combination that he that he did whether
it was intentional or not
mentored by buddy holly and frank
sinatra lopez became an international
star
one who would perform both in english
and spanish
the story goes when he was in l.a
he was playing at some club
and frank sinatra happened to be
happened to go in
one night and basically discovered him
one thing's for sure lopez was always
proud to be
a mexicano he was in the movie the dirty
dozen
so watching him on tv as well you know
which is kind of cool
oh yeah aside from that gibson guitar
corporation
commissioned a signature piece the trini
lopez guitar
a couple years later they did another
signature one but it was more of a
solid more like a rock version of it
today many stars like dave grohl of foo
fighters and no gallagher of oasis carry
those collector items
lopez was inducted into the
international latin music hall of fame
in 2003
in a las vegas walk of stars in 2008.
many musicians like chavez narrow say he
will always be
a role model to follow i love his
singing voice
the way that he would project the way
that he would work the crowd
over you know a lot of a lot of fun and
it's infectious
he has such a positive vibe so i would
like myself to be
positive as well chavez says trini lopez
paved the way for latino americans
such as santana they have a musical
legacy
that they leave behind and it's up to us
to
you know keep to keep that legacy going
and with his
hammer and song
may you rest in peace trini lopez sally
jaramillo
i
reporting